aquí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cada tanto se una cerca a alguien que no
conozco en nada me dice algo así como os
sigue la beat en la vía lo come
y yo lo miro y digo que le digo
y le digo cosas que si ahora sí tienen
un tiempito te cuento que hizo casi
siempre quien así que yo le cuento que
fui a un colegio de curas y desde el
primer grado y hasta cuarto año que
justo fue el año que me quedé de año y
ya de paso aprovecharon y me echaron
si hoy en la distancia el recuerdo más
lindo que tengo el de los compañeros
créanme que esos 45 monos estamos
preparados para todos era algo así como
un grupo comando de élite de los
servicios secretos del colegio obvio
ejemplo entraron y cubra el reactor que
tenía la peor pero la peor de todas y
decía si no se entrega ya mismo el
degenerado hijo del [ __ ] que tiró la
bombita de dolor en el aula de
amonestaciones colectiva más de uno se
va a quedar libre
y nosotros tranquilos
fumando largo temple de acero lo hago
porque ellos lo curan nos va bien
entrenado para soportar las presiones
más violentas pero ahora no se habían
dado cuenta que tenían el enemigo
adentro
y como nadie se movía en dos el cura que
hacía se ponía loco del todo y no sacaba
a trotar al patio donde nos congelábamos
nos dejaba sin recreo durante unas
semanas seguidas pero todo por dentro es
que hay algo de la risa porque en
definitiva esa penitencia era un chiste
lo malo malo malo ese colegio es que no
teníamos contacto con chicas
los libros biología no se lo deseo ni al
peor de los enemigos en todos los
colegios del mundo deberían ser mixtos
pero un día y la profesora de literatura
que era más mala que las arañas y no me
piden que le da el nombre saben
perfectamente que no se los puedo dar
laura aranda se ama
mala mala mala araña y no dice así como
el pasar que represento la escuela un
festival intercolegial de teatro que
organiza la municipalidad y como la obra
interpretar tenía varios personajes
femeninos no le había quedado otra
opción y hace una coproducción con un
colegio de monjas que obviamente estaba
lleno de femeninas
gracias dios mío benedicto dijimos todos
los masculinos al unísono
tanto año y a misa y por lo mismo que al
fin al caos hice un poco de justicia
divina
el casting una locura se presentó todo
el mundo y ahí no hubo compañerismo que
valga no señor ahí todo el mundo fue con
los tapones de punta dio el primero
codazo en la cara patada por la espalda
por esa cosa rarísima de la vida yo que
jugaba a la pelota todo el día
y con lo único que soñaba con jugar la
selección argentina algún día que es
seleccionado pero para hacer el papel
protagónico de la obra que salva el
carnaval del [ __ ] que era una especie
de culebrón gauchesco donde le juro que
tenía más letras que lo moderno miren me
acuerdo como si fuese hoy el día del
estreno porque mi nona antonio estaba
sentada en la primera fila y yo salgo de
escena por primera vez en mi vida piso
el escenario y digo no no lo digo lo
hago
ave maría purísima
literalmente explotó a la platea
aplausos gritos silbidos yo dije no a
nada esto no me está pasando a mí esto
no me apareció a la alegría yo quiero
hacer esto todos los días de mi vida y
así fue como de muy chico encontré la
vocación de actor y dejé de jugar a la
pelota para siempre y me dediqué para
siempre jugar esto de la interpretación
pero la alegría como saben no dura para
toda la vida porque ese año me llevé
alguna materia más alguna otra que tenía
previa me terminé quedando de año como
un nabo el 12 de marzo justo el día de
mi cumpleaños
bingo mi viejo que hacían lo que podían
para joderme un poco más la vida
obviamente lo primero que me dijeron fue
que me olvidara del viaje de estudio a
bariloche lo segundo que no iban a
alimentar vagos así que nos pusieron a
mi arma me a mí una carnicería
verdulería en barrio alberdi y lo
tercero me anotaron de prepo en un
colegio nocturno san vicente mami un año
duro duro duro
la buena noticia de la nocturna es que
era mixto
así que apenas entré sentí que tenía
recuperar todo el tiempo perdido a los
10 minutos no malgasto de novio con una
colorada uruguaya que me encantaba la
otra buena noticia fue que la profesora
literatura me reconoció por el gran
trabajo actoral en el carnaval del
[ __ ] y me convocó para hacer la
fablilla del secreto bien guardado obra
en la que hice viejo y la obra van a la
obra
ahora anduvo muy bien quería
un fracaso no figuramos ni en los
programas de manos así que también de
chiquito aprendí que alegó hay que
tenerlo muy bien controlado con esta
profesión nadie pero nadie la tiene
atada y que hoy está arriba y mañana a
la mañana estás abajo es que el éxito
como dijo el viejo y querido napoleón no
es ganar siempre sino no desanimarse
nunca lo triste de ese año fue que
cuando estrenamos mi nona antonia ya no
estaba y en la primera fila porque hacía
poquito se abrió el cielo y la verdad
que se dice hasta hoy para mí ya nada
fue lo mismo después la carnicería
verdulería trabajé de un montón de cosas
pero de un montón de pero siempre a la
par haciendo teatro ido haciendo porque
soy autodidacta y creo profundamente la
autoformación porque depende pura y
exclusivamente las ganas que le ponga
cada uno para formarse y puedo
asegurarles que yo le pongo y le puse
unas ganas desmesurada
es que me acuesto y me levanto pensando
viendo leyendo escribiendo pero sobre
todo haciendo teatro por eso
independientemente lo que hagan a mí me
parece que está buenísimo hacer no tener
miedo a hacer
porque si sale bien nos cogemos un asado
y brindamos y si sale mal nos comemos un
asado y brindamos
porque se aprende igual es más casi
siempre se aprende mucho más cuando sale
mal que cuando sale bien por eso para mí
esta es la mejor escuela de todas porque
nunca se acaba porque nunca te recibís
de nada pero vivís aprendiendo de los
otros y con los otros todo el tiempo
hace mucho tiempo yo hacía una obra de
teatro que tenía mucho despliegue físico
y realmente terminamos alcanza bueno una
noche vino mi mamá con una de su hermana
mi tía leche que era una divina y para
terminar la función mi tía le dice me
ama hb que bajar de la ley tanto trabajo
para no trabajar
y eso es lo que piensan ustedes que esto
nuevo un trabajo y que por ende no
deberíamos festejar el primero de mayo
que general se un actor famoso que la
gente para la calle te pide autógrafos y
que si no son millonarios porque
definitivamente son muy malos ahora lo
más loco todo y dígame si no es cierto
cuando usted lo ven a brad pitt o johnny
depp a leo dica porque está todo bien
pues son muy muy amigos me los 3
pero ustedes piensan sobre todo las
chicas impresionante cómo trabajan estos
guacha o hasta tres películas por años
se clavan pero es más loco esto como
estuve ni bajan de peso con lo que me
costaría a mí hacer esto miren chicas yo
le ves una sola cosa si a mí me llegan a
para el 10% que digo que el 1% de la
guita que ganan mis amigos hollywood a
verme como una vaca entera una holando
argentino me clava una damajuana de
servir de vino te subo 230 quienes un
día al otro día te lo adelgazo y te
bailo la sílfide completa acá en la isla
de los patos
un poquito de respeto
por acá también está lleno de robert de
niro y al pacino y hablando lo mismo
pero de lo mismo el marlon brando
cordobés que para mí es mario me saca a
quien yo amo tanto como marlon brando un
día me dijo al oído que yo me lo grabé a
fuego para toda la vida hermano al
teatro hay que darle todo sin pedirle
nada a cambio si el teatro algún día te
devuelve algo bienvenido sea y si no no
pasa nada porque esto sólo se hace por
amor por pasión por vocación que puedo
asegurar y eso tuve muchos años
económicamente muy mal pero muy malo lo
que me conocen saben que en un momento
determinado mi vida yo solo tenía una
hija y una bici
o hasta un día más la bici en la puerta
del terror real y cómo salir solo me
queda una hija
antonia sí claro más vale comino no por
suerte y también lo tengo al bebo y ala
me persigue nunca me quejé y nunca me
voy a quejar porque realmente es un
bajón estar quejándose todo el tiempo
por eso es un agradecido de la vida por
eso me levanto todos los días de mi vida
a luchar por mis sueños ser cada día un
poquito mejor actor y como es de ser es
bien nacido ser agradecido hay dos cosas
que no quiero dejar de contar la primera
es que una noche y no verme el teatro
laura aranda
si la profesora literatura de cuarto año
y le puedes ir así en la cara a los mala
más la mala que era cuando nosotros
chicos yo me acuerdo que ella se reía
mucho pero también pude darle un abrazo
y decirle que yo era lo que era y está
donde estaba gracias a ella la otra cosa
que otra noche en otro teatro vino a
verme y que era el actual director del
colegio de cura y que yo había ido pero
lo que no era cura y sabe que me dijo
que ahora el colegio era mixto
dios existe pensé para mis adentros y el
loco me dijo que fuera algún día a
hablar con la chica y con los chicos y
obviamente que fui y cuando fui al
principio no no no me di cuenta porque
efectivamente estaba el lleno de chicas
y chicos y la verdad que era hermoso
verlos a todos juntos ahí en ese colegio
pero de a poco empezaron a aparecer los
verdaderos personajes de esta historia
que les quiero contar muchas maestras
mías de la primaria la secundaria muchos
compañeros menos de toda la vida de
pronto apareció mi mamá estaba muy
emocionada mi papá ya no estaba
hubiese sido lindo que hubiese estado
ahí él antonino para que escuchara lo
que dijo el director el director dijo
que a pesar de que sabía cómo me habían
echado de la escuela de que a pesar de
que sabía que todavía tenía algunas
materias previas a ver matemáticas de
cuarto de quinto física de cuarto y
química de quinto
pero que igual me va a hacer entrega del
pin de este pin que tengo acá como si yo
hubiese egresado de la escuela pues
según dijo de ahí habían salido
reconocidos deportistas políticos
científicos pero que yo
había sido el único artista
hace poco leí un artículo con un título
muy [ __ ] pero muy [ __ ] que decía el
mundo está enfermo ya sé que no hay que
ser ni gandini mandela ni la madre
teresa para darse cuenta de eso estamos
todos de acuerdo por lo que usted nos
imaginan es el motivo de la enfermedad
decía que más de la mitad de la
población del mundo mundial se pasa el
75% de su vida trabajando de algo que no
les da alegría trabajando de algo que no
los hace felices y como si eso fuese
poco debido a eso precisamente se
enferman y se mueren trabajando de algo
que no aman no soy político
no soy sociólogo no soy filosofía y no
tengo ni la más prostituta idea cómo se
hace para cambiar este mundo
pero de algo estoy totalmente convencido
que hoy es el momento justo para empezar
a cambiar tu mundo que quieres ser
bailarín a los 80 años hacerlo estar a
tiempo que quieres ser inspector de
axila buenísimo hacerlo está a tiempo y
voy a crecer cantante lírico a cero está
a tiempo de nuevo la háganlo están a
tiempo y van a ver que cuando empiecen a
hacer lo que les gusta es verdad
el mundo va a empezar a cambiar de
verdad
el mundo se ha empezar a curar
la toca pavón para llevar a la que la
toca para lo que él quiera para cambiar
gente para el 10 para alejandro que la
para y le pasa la pelota a los
espectadores del tec 2018
ahora la pelota está de su lado ojalá se
anime pero tiene que ser pronto porque
desde tanto esperada se han muerto los
inmortales de tanto esperar hemos
olvidado lo inolvidable al sabio conocer
los labios al profeta sacar la careta al
artista dormido el tacto el olfato el
oído y la vista y adiós adiós lo que
quede quedará la resaca de una
borrachera el perfume una rosa en
primavera la mirada del león el latido
del corazón han muerto los inmortales
hemos olvidado lo inolvidable pero aún
estamos vivos vivos vivos sin pecados
concebidos honremos el viaje del niño al
viejo al compás del tic tac al tick tack
de louis ven ven ven ven que yo te
quiero ver bailar ven ven ven que yo te
quiero oír cantar vivos estamos vivos
sin pecados concebidos que respeten mis
oídos que no engañan mi mirada para
decir lo que nos dicen que no nos digan
nada nada de nada
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah